hi I'm Erik Bosse and the trailer for
Avengers 4 has allegedly linked with a
very unconformity the rounds online now
it's clear to anyone reading this this
is very likely fan generated it just
feels too good to be true real life is
just more disappointing than that but to
be safe I thought we would piece
together what this band trailer would
look like after analyzing movie trailers
for several years and knowing quite a
bit about how real movies are
constructed I think I can help sort out
what stuff could actually be legit and
what's probably fan fiction and spoiler
warning in case this description is real
may almighty Thanos not smite me for my
skepticism nor demand nice silencing
here we go the trailer starts off
showing the damaged Infinity Gauntlet in
a field on the foreign planet as the
camera focuses in on the gauntlet we
hear Tony's voice we were destined to
lose epic music score starts hello
alright it sounds plausible enough
though I gotta say I think the Avengers
directors and the team producing this
trailer will be a little more nuanced
than opening the trailer like previously
on Avengers montage honestly this one
reminds me a lot of Patton Oswalt's nerd
rant on Parks and Rec what he wanted the
opening shot of Star Wars Episode 7 to
be the gloved Mandalorian armor gauntlet
of Boba Fett grabs onto the sand outside
the Charlotte alright let's move on the
Quinn jet is shown landing in a wakandan
wasteland as we hear Steve Rogers say
we've come so far Tony and nebula
step off the jet as the remaining
Avengers approach Steve as a look of
relief and says Tony Tony seeming
defeated shakes his head and gives a
friendly smirk back to cap okay some
issues here Tony Stark and nebula were
stranded on Titan they didn't have the
Quinn jet and even though the Quinn jet
can travel through space this would have
to apply cap somehow set the Quinn jet
remotely to space out of Titan I just
think they get back to earth differently
now the image of a wakandan wasteland is
interesting like all countries what kind
of must be devastated to have half of
its population suddenly vanished but the
rumor is that Avengers 4 will take place
several years after infinity war and
this subtle exchange between Tony and
Steve just sounds like an imagined
reunion moment that fans have wanted
since their breakup in civil war let's
move on Marvel Studios logo
years we get a glimpse of the Battle of
New York from 2012 Avengers location
looking shocked and baffled as he is on
the top of stark tower there's a flash
of Buddha light as the camera pans back
man okay this part sounds inspired by
some of the actual rumors and leaks set
photos for the Avengers for movies the
most popular theory is that the movie
will feature some kind of time travel
back to past MCU moments including the
Battle of New York and spoiler warning
again but we have seen some set photos
of our TJ and Tom Hiddleston appearing
to restage that Loki and start
confrontation in stark tower it's just
hard to know whether this trailer
description was based on that gossip or
it confirms the gossip it's a classic
chicken and Easter egg dilemma and I
should say that showing Loki being alive
again after very clearly and very
uncomfortably hearing his neck crack in
Infinity Ward it's a pretty mind-blowing
reveal to just drop so casually early in
a trailer right yeah moving on next we
see the wakandan throne with mbaku at
the helm he's surrounded by his new
Kingsguard a mix of the hilltribe and
the door melash a cherie and banner are
seen working on a new project in the lab
so I guess it's interesting I've been
wondering who would take over the
wakandan thrown into challahs absence
and I assumed it would be sure he has
the next in line and the most likely to
have her own black panther suit that
she'd wear but yeah vodka would
certainly be the strongest leader let
them with Conda and I don't see anyone
beating him at warrior Falls and sure he
could still be the hero of Black Panther
and just leave maka to rule the kingdom
so I guess this one checks out but let's
move on Black Widow in full gear is in
hot guys family home from age of Ultron
basically everything is thrown all over
the place and broken natus studying some
type of math of multiple photos and
locations on it okay so this is hinting
at the theory for Hawkeye storyline that
we've discussed before that hawkeye's
whole family wife and two kids will have
dusted after the snap leading to Clint
smashing of his house and adding to the
mess that Thor caused an age of Ultron
is - she such trauma could lead Clint to
the darker edgier Ronan storyline in
which in the comics he becomes an
assassin in Japan which we've speculated
based on that new haircut and costume
and set photos and unsurprisingly this
trailer description fully leans into
that
a quick shot of Thanos is shown with the
long sword walking it down an alleyway
in New York City the next shot is a dark
hooded figure with glowing eyes aiming a
bow and arrow before shooting toward the
camera okay so this image to Thanos with
the sword was concept art that was
released along with that group shot with
Hulk and a unitard but just so you know
art like this is composed for all big
property movies and it's not official
it's just meant to brainstorm different
visuals for the story as it's being
dreamt up like think about it widest
Thanos need a sword certainly got
Infinity stones we didn't see him with a
sword in that Gamora flashback maybe he
gets a new one but again this just all
feels like a reach to me next one to two
visuals with a quantum realm Scotland no
suit is shown running through a park
dodging explosions
a shot of space Thor and Valkyrie are
aboard a Kree ship if the stories are
true your universe passcode is okay if
people watching this channels videos as
of late theories surrounding Scott and
the quantum realms setting up Avengers 4
are very popular but it's this third
part that gets me a little skeptical
everything we know about Thor and
Valkyrie as characters tells us that
they are just too cocky to tell an
unknown like Carol Danvers to her face
that she's universes last hope the Thor
we know is a warrior he'd go for bar
mounts the farmhouse chop down every
door with Stormbreaker and plan to aim
for the head this time
and what legends would Thor have heard
like if Odinson knew of these stories of
a crazy powerful earth woman he would
have brought it up by now so yeah I'm
thinking fake next the next shot is an
older determined Tony Stark walking
through the new shield HQ that's
Avengers facility in upstate New York
he's in full shield attire carrying an
orange briefcase spanner wearing spandex
is seen running from something looking
terrified
so this description assumes that shield
will relaunch somehow with Tony Stark's
resources which I guess makes sense in
the aftermath of the snap I would
imagine the remaining forces pooling
their resources like that but this
orange briefcase comes from another set
photo showing a prop orange briefcase
with binary augmented retro framing
written on it that's of course referring
to poor the hologram technology stark
showed MIT students in Civil War now I'm
not sure if this briefcase that we saw
in the photo is a prop or if it's like
set equipment containing a different
birth related prop there has also been
some speculation that rather than
literal
Travel the avengers could use Starks
Barth technology to revisit memories of
these past battles a kind of x-men
danger room kind of thing moving on the
next shot is ant-man appearing out of a
flash of light and landing in a desolate
place we see it from his point of view
from inside his helmet he looks left to
right and to his left again and says
what enough camera focuses on Boromir
and it stars okay the idea here is that
ant-man strip through the quantum realm
will spit him out on Boromir the planet
from infinity war where the soul stone
resided this also just feels a little
convenient me suggesting that that space
stone wormhole that Foose tread skull -
Boromir and Captain America is the same
kind of portal that Scott will use to
escape the quantum realm I might be
wrong but I just don't think Avengers 4
will return - Boromir as a location at
all it just kind of felt like a
one-and-done kind of place to me moving
on next a shot of rocket and nebula
modifying some new weapons in the lab
rocket says Lincoln we tried this bad
boy out and they smile at each other in
his thumb okay no nebula doesn't fist
bump next we get our first glimpse of
Iron Man and it's red and gold nanotech
armor Paul falls from the sky and lands
in front of a fan of the full armor
smiles all smiles back Tony's new red
and gold armor has been described in
some low-res leaked concept art which
looks inspired by the model for armor
from the comics and I assume of interest
for will feature some kind of fist fight
rematch between Thanos and Hulk since
Hulk wouldn't cut out to play for most
of infinity war ice and the filmmakers
are saving the goods for the final
showdown let's move on the next shot is
in Japan war machine man Steve in their
full Avengers here surrounded by the
Yakuza Hawkeye ruling
walk through everybody from behind and
then approaches the Avengers there's an
intensive stage of whoops between
Clinton etosha okay so I assume this
scene would be like a follow-up to that
description of Natasha and Clint smashed
farmhouse earlier and I guess the
suggestion is that she and cap and
Rhodey tracked down Clint to Japan
finding him running the Japanese crime
world we have seen some set photos of a
city block with signs and Japanese
there's also a rumor of a casting notice
for actors to play Yakuza
we're actually scroll Impostors so I get
where this imagery is coming from I just
don't think the real trailer would give
us all of this information so early like
Marvel trailers typically play things a
bit closer to the chest and this
description reads like major reveal
after major reveals well I even see
Avengers for when we could just read
this description let's move on next shot
is at the sanctum Wang is communicating
with dr. Strange's Seoul via portal
customer gray-haired Tony Stark and
ant-man are in a post-apocalyptic NYC
now I will admit that I like the idea of
Doctor Strange haunting the surviving
characters a ghost form but if a mere
conjured pearl is all that's needed to
chat with them doesn't that kind of
cheap in his death and again really any
deceased character appearing in this
trailer would be mind-blowing
showing multiple of them and one trailer
would just be too much and yeah Tony and
Scott and post-apocalyptic NYC it's
pretty much a literal description of
that lead set photo next the screen
flashes back and forth multiple times
throughout multiple scenes we see
Captain Marvel floating with their fists
on fire in her eyes lit up
Thanos in the soulstone with young
Kimura screaming at him Loki and Thor
fighting off to tari together and Tony
handed Steve a brand new shield what
kind of throne room okay well this
description at least understands the
escalate to rapid intercounty montage
formula of all actually movie trailers
fanservice e o massive payoffs that
Marvel might give us one of in a trailer
if we're lucky moving on it cuts back to
Tony and Skye
Tony opens the orange briefcase to Scott
handsome and then lumen ated bracelet
Tony asks is
Iron Man and ant-man are shown traveling
through the quantum realm it's got her
back in the Battle of New Year 2012 okay
again this whole description is trying
to piece together various set photo
imagery but the narrative it's creating
has just too many inconsistencies first
if that orange briefcase had barf
written on it why would stark be the one
to be confused by it also why would any
trailer be ordered in such a way as to
show us various shots of Loki alive in
the Battle of New York in the trailer
and then present the idea the quantum
realm time travel as a twist reveal like
you think would be the other way around
introduced the idea of quantum time
travel and then show us the implications
of it like getting to see characters
alive again but you know super fans just
don't think linearly they blew their
rods and then they try to just tie and
it brings me to the big trailer moment
the final shot afford the title reveal
is an infinity stone disappearing from
Thanos is damaged gauntlet he abruptly
gets up and puts on his armor the space
goes from extremely imperii ated to a
menacing smile tidal reveal Avengers
annihilation now to be fair Thanos seen
one of the Infinity stones suddenly
fading away from the gauntlet the same
way the snap victims suddenly faded away
would be a very cool sight but here's
what confuses me how does a super
in-depth trailer description presumably
written by a witness perceptive enough
to describe strux armor or the planet
for me or the color of a briefcase not
tell us the color of the Infinity stone
that disappeared he tell us what color
the damn briefcase was you couldn't tell
us whether Thanos has to fight without
the green time stone or the red reality
stone like even if the Russos Tarantino
this shot into worried black and white
you could still tell by the damn
placement also just a little weird to
follow this major image of hope with a
downer title like annihilation like I
know Avengers annihilation has been
going around online for the past few
weeks but I'm sorry I just don't see
Marvel naming their most important movie
the same title as the second Mortal
Kombat movie and of course because this
fan description is going for extra
credit it includes a trailer post title
stinger
the home his training at the new shield
facility with Black Widow and Steve
Steve notices that Hocus been training
non-stop as a CLE so we asked why Hulk
responds in banners normal voice with my
rematch is coming real soon I can feel
it okay I get it
professor Hulk with banner having
complete cognitive control over the
Hulk's body is something that lots of
fans including me have been wanting to
see it's just the dialogue doesn't sound
anything like any professor would say or
any movie character would say unless I
guess they're in Mortal Kombat
annihilation so there it is you're
Avengers 4 trailer description which I
think I've more or less proven to be fan
compos'd that said I am fully willing to
eat humble pie if this ends up being the
exact description of the trailer good
boy would that be embarrassing but
here's my question for you which of
these unlikely images do you think would
be the most likely to appear in the reel
of interest forward trailer comment down
below with your thoughts and follow me
on twitter and instagram at a box and
subscribe to new rock stars for
breakdowns of actual trailers when they
come out including the one for Avengers
for which I assume was already broken
down shot-for-shot exactly by Patton
Oswalt in Parks and Rec you gotta check
this out Tony Shrek realizes that there
has been a disturbance in what he will
call a time ribbon yep the time ribbon
confirmed thanks Patton
[Music]